okay a quick update last we spoke I was
telling you a lot I was trying to remove
it in new studios this is actually the
old space but we're going through
inventory I wanted you to meet my mom
tonight who's our wardrobe designer
stylist here come on come on internet
you see this is this is where they do a
lot of editing this is this is one room
actually where my mom does a lot of we
do a lot of changing this is where
myself not gay generally millennial and
Blair White and Clint Howard have all
found themselves naked at some point so
or moving into a new space we actually
had unfortunately some stuff kind of
fall through but we have a lot to do and
February 1st is going to be an
incredible show mom we show them your
wardrobe well I don't want to let the
costume in the makeup that goes into
this show it's it's it's silly we don't
have a full-on set this is false in and
that'll be relevant later because they
have some labels here to show you so my
mother leaves you later we'll need you
later this is the green screen area as
you see and this is the old space and
we've outgrown it the actual studio
would record the full podcast is next
room this is all being done in inventory
because we're moving into a new space to
serve you better this is constant show
them what what is this whole room as you
can see this is we're out of space yep
well those are all the costume that we
use for the show like some of them you
know very well a deep on trainee Bain
Donald Trump I mean just so many many
many of yeah here we have full this is
the same thing Jean gr character that's
right here Colton so we have it just all
established character different one
fantasy one wall beads knee Emma we got
two one one was overcrowded for those
who as we moved to a new space as we
expand everything and also get some
better equipment cameras uploading
abilities to get you guys more content
for those four mugs up members
we had to go through a whole new
labeling system yes and this is an
action well self-storage with an
entirely separate storage area just for
costumes makeup discs drives so show us
your area here I want to show people who
don't know this is some of the problems
we ran into you know what's about to
happen
so motels have been cleared but see yes
understand I grew up with a
french-canadian mom and Maggie jr. it
takes me sides is what what's what's
going on here because of the labeling no
god this is not funny god bless picture
you in a second why he's doing your best
she's doing her best
she speaks fluently but the writing not
too much so that's how the labels look
in here you have hat and this is the
first one - what's that word Hasek check
what is chick mean sick is what it's a
it's a it's like a beanie it's a catch
it's a beanie yeah we have took what is
this can you get that day you can get it
in there in a hospital gown that's how
you cuz that's how you think he's
falling out today we have knifes props
and you something is so adorable about
my mother
she put this on here because she thought
that the giant rubber dick dick molester
son Dayton lost her son was less vulgar
she said this would be less offensive I
can't let people see that those are fun
expenses to follow just by this guy's
naked underwear breast implant we could
only afford one be more my club members
we're gonna get the brawls that's funder
expense and then my personal favorite
this is the one you know this one
Mackey Jarrod says I I don't know I'm at
a loss all right oh yeah okay okay so
Jarrod read that first gee doof doof hat
drift hat and sideburn so let me show
you those hence the reason for new
inventory ot yarmulke
Francine what's what is it what does
this actually say what does that mean
Jew hat in French and sideburn wasn't a
big chunky would often refer to all of
you drift banker she does all the
Wardrobe all the makeup it's become you
know this is a mom-and-pop shop and not
a Jared and we're so excited for
February first to bring some bigger
better things in and honestly just like
we had so much space it got you know
you've when you get you grow up you into
space it gets hard to operate within it
so this is a long time coming and then
we also just had other things that
weren't we weren't capable of getting
the show on time
so um she's been great mislabelling some
stuff we're gonna work on that February
1st we have some awesome guests and a
backlog of some sketches that we've been
working on what we can looking forward
to seeing you then that's here in the
YouTube channel my club this video
subscribe by clicking the letters that
spell out subscribe also YouTube
somewhere in this box has a recommended
video for you now I don't know what they
recommend but my guest says if you're
here it's going to be something twisted
and something you don't want your
parents to see if you want to see the
entire show from which this clip is
taken click one of the boxes playing
next to me that is the full episode or
join the mug Club for the daily show the
reason the daily show isn't on YouTube
is because
well YouTube isn't like some of the
things we say